you
okay this is one hour of crazy house
chess crazy house tournament one hour
time controls three two you still can
berserk in this case you I believe lose
half your time if you bruiser Q lose
half your time and you play without an
increment so let's see Bishop here right
away
striking it f7 so alright let's open it
up let's crack it this guy already
let's take with the Queen I'm hitting
here yeah I think the most important
thing is just to focus on now focus on
the clock so much but yeah okay very
tempted to go here hmm too early too
early
hmm I come all the way back just to
secure some squares for peace drops okay
you're gonna take a night huh let's get
this in there okay I got to watch out
for a tricky Knight who may appear
anywhere oh man like right here alright
let's go here see what you got I liked
the additional reason behind this was to
stop a pawn drop on this square hmm I
think I want to have a pond right there
secure some squares I have a bishop they
have a pawn mm-hmm okay
how about getting your Bishop out hmm
okay I guess we'll develop tough to say
yeah all right let's take that and do
what next
the Knights going to go here maybe okay
tell you what tell you what let's drop a
knight right here this is strong square
for a knight not threatening this they
could make it maybe just move their
knight here that could hurt I could
definitely hurt yeah it feels like I
think it will hurt hmm no boy
the with something like a pawn drop on
f3 or Knight f3 stuff oh boy oh they're
starting with that move interesting well
things are about to get a little nutty
really huh tell you what I'm going to
take that I could take this bishop at
any moment with check so if I need
another Bishop I've got that Queens hit
let's just go here see if they drop
something if they go here they then
maybe I could drop something here at
some stage okay let's come here defend
this pawn oh really now let's try that
less than a minute look at all these
other games that are finished Wow
this an hour turn
Ament though got to keep winning hmm
it's tough to really commentate there's
just so much going on okay well this is
an opportunity to maybe drop something
here is this my moment to strike
hmm take here I don't know
let's take there
ah okay
not a good idea on my part
yikes oh boy
I'm in big trouble
and they take spawn oh man they could do
a pawn drop right here okay you still
have a lot of pieces though
yikes hitting tonight right now I need
to get some peace in there now clean
check I missed that
I'm going to take my rook I'm toast man
oh boy
Queen takes pawn dropping a lot of stuff
don't make me draw - draw isn't it it's
a draw
um let's try that
oh I just got mated wine I see that it's
so obvious c4 pawn drop exclam ah man my
King got ripped to shreds okay let's try
another round
clearly 51 minutes ah that's rough man
that's rough okay
okay there's 87 in here now there we go
Oh a chest friend I have to come harder
at the black King there there we go
mm-hmm
yeah I have to disrupt the King position
quicker let's start off with that and
then connect it let's see if we can make
some magic happen like that there you go
okay now maybe here and play quicker
maybe let's see
yikes first place guys and he's got nine
Wow okay hmm all right let's run away
that's a nice square for a pawn or a
knight some pretty suit that's a serious
gap Castle get the rook here yeah this
should be good there huh all right let's
stop what start wit upon here Bishop
here check maybe I was too quick to put
a piece there may be a bishop would have
been better hmm
I did see that move
okay huh all right let's see what they
have here Bishop takes pawn takes Knight
h4 gotta get my queen out first okay I
have a pawn in a bishop hmm I don't know
let's try this Knight takes Knight I
could do this double check move
okay let's recapture with the rook okay
there must be something good here huh
hmm where are some crazy tactics takes
here and then maybe I don't know if I
want to start taking too many more
pieces Queen g3 is interesting get a
night in a rook
let's try that okay actually I do see
something where I could drop a rope here
I have a rook two bishops and a knight
let's start with this control some
squares around the King a block huh I do
anything dangerous with my knight take
the rook okay let's do this actually and
then drop the knight into this square
they might take with the king now let's
do this
actually I'm gonna get the Queen now
regardless of where the Queen oh yeah
don't forget about their sideboard oh
boy yeah there is that move okay King
prepare to run oh boy oh no yikes I'm
toast
it's me I think I'd to go here if I went
here I think I'd get mated with clean
here in a rook here I gotta go in this
direction it's probably still going to
be me yikes this is too close oh man
yeah gotta go here oh they have a
discovered check or that tricky hop man
Knight g5 back to tournament Oh for two
we're still going to soldier on I'm
looking for the front page the front
page is where I want to be maybe I
should be shooting for top 50
oh let's see what the fern page looks
like oh look at this guy who's he who is
he
ah man I got too fixated on oh I'm
attacking the Queen the Queen us to move
mm-hmm not so fast buddy they have the
initiative Wow
okay I guess we're going to try this oh
man I don't even know if this is a good
idea
Wow maybe in the end my goal will be to
score one win yeah they're ready okay
all right I need to get some pieces out
threatening upon ah man they they killed
me in that last one there normally I'd
be a little bit hesitant with castling
but if there isn't an F pawn here and
you have this play okay so they don't
have any drops that's nice hmm
I guess I will take like this to bishops
how would I put them here now I don't
want to drop too soon I want to give
them too much material let's get more
pieces out I'd like to see them drop
their Knights somewhere so I don't have
to worry about him
checkmating me like in the last game all
right think this is a good start your
next pile up on the pinned piece mmm I
might just take that hmm
let's keep the pin going to do this that
creates some serious gaps
we're nearly 20 minutes in and I'm
looking for my first point my first win
uh-huh
now let's take here no now we're going
to start bringing the pain there you go
there you go now we're cooking now we're
cooking get rid of him watch out for a
crazy Bishop to appear anywhere hmm okay
all right there we go
invite my pawn forward I want a pond on
white side of the board all right hang
on seize the initiative now that's so
fast Knight here take here and then give
a check I'm liking this game so far
let's do this two nights in the bishop
how to take on this square hmm take here
I could take again and drop a knight
here okay it feels
like I am so far off from even being on
streak quick like this fire here is just
you know it's like it's so far off hmm
all right now this is where we start
bringing the pain I think I hope
starting with the bishop here oh really
I will gladly take that now I have four
Knights didn't see that move coming but
I my bishop indirectly defended tricky
Knight
watch out oh yeah give me that clean I
have three bishops I have three nights
in a queen and that's with check okay
come on now come on now you got this you
got this starting with that hit it g3
width check this has got to be winning
no no way so now we'll take you a check
this should be a forced mate look at all
this firepower look at all this
firepower start with the rook yes
you got this you got this what's where's
the mate let's check prima mate
yay got the first W whoo watch out I'm
in 69th coming up the ranks all right
pairing number four pair me up with the
top dog let me at him let me Adam 18 I
got this
I got this I'm at 299 players are in
this one already am I gonna get paired
up okay here we go here we go
epic comeback starts right here watch
out for Peyton Manning you know what I
mean
alrighty then Bishop f5 mm let's go
there
all right night you need to go alright
get developed maybe it's too early to
bring a night out yeah I thought you
might do that okay let's see what you
got
pawn drop on this square at some stage
and night hmm
tricky tricky tricky already alright
let's see how you react to that rules
out a night check you have to move
faster huh put some pressure on them is
that the trick yeah just take pieces
prepared to run wild that's a check
I got a knight and a bishop make some
magic happen
and upon Wow
this guy's a master defender a master
defender alright do I even recapture
there I think I need to start start
attacking huh what do you say what do
you say oh really now let's take with
that it's afraid of a bishop drop
getting this guy okay it's time to bring
the pain work some magic knight Knight
h4 pressure points bishop g3 hmm I'm not
afraid of that okay this is where things
start this is where we make stuff happen
now there we go there we go you could do
it you could do it that's a fork king
here you move the knight away and then
you threaten a bishop G to move you have
a bishop that you could take bishop drop
on g2 next I really insist on just
smashing through here hmm I got no
pieces no pieces hmm
let's do that
you
Wow okay now let's take some stuff
grab a pond grab a knight grab another
pond this should be enough fuel right
they don't even have anything going
around my king yet I could grab a bishop
this should be enough this should be
enough attacking material right okay
they only a pawn I have to worry about
smothered mate wood apone all right -
Knights to bishops upon really want to
take here and drop another night here 22
how does somebody already have 20 - my
goodness let's just grab another one two
pawns a night in a bishop
they have nothing in reserve
let's do this I'm preparing to take and
drop another night here and have some
security case the King approaches I'm
all ready for my my final uh combination
here not quite sure what it's going to
be but it starts with that okay night
make it happen oh that's definitely
happening okay let's take a look they
have a knight in a pond huh I could get
a rook right here though
Queens defending drop a piece here now
this has to be good they resigned they
felt the pain coming alright we're at
four we're on streak we're on fire we
are not going to get first almost at the
halfway point here we go mm okay maybe
these guys have a lot of experience with
the game in there they're able to win
some early combination that I'm not
aware of that's a lot he's heard a lot
of points man all right let's take that
let's drop him right away actually why
not focus on that hole right here one
one weak point okay
let's take him out strike here I could
drop a knight here at any moment okay
let's get
thing here maybe okay hmm it's about a
night here maybe take a pond drop one
here might be threatening mate in a
couple like Queen here here I take some
combination of dropping upon on these
two squares night has these two this one
is this one pollen drops on these two
will cover the last two let's see how
they react are they going to drop a
bishop or push okay I might be able to
take that hmm
okay I'm going to take care here that
move let's develop and strike oh I have
a night move here you goof I should have
considered this in-betweener okay you're
definitely getting there right now come
on you must have something good right
now do it connect those pieces right
around the enemy King that's a
backbreaker isn't it that's got to be
Bishop f6 Oh got to be good now we're
threatening this Forex everywhere pawn
drop pawn takes it's got to be good
I got a bishop in a knight though okay
the pawn drop here for starters yeah
where's the mean take the rook with's
check take here
I'm on the Queen yeah right threatening
to take the Queen and get a queen
okay let's throw this check in first and
then think about taking next to be
careful queen drops rook drop here this
is mate they take I take their queen and
then I drop my queen here I have a queen
and that's me got it back to tournament
whoo I have eight I'm on streak less
than half an hour's not long enough for
this tournament at this time control has
anybody been berserk and yeah you can
breeze urk there's fives up there efore
let's pinpoint that f7 square mm okay
I'm going to take care it's probably
it's too early isn't it my plan is to
take on f7 right away and then play
Knight here drop the pawn too early to
do this let's try that
caveman chess
caveman crazy house a quick f7 strike
followed up with the fork there you go
get that rook go get him go hunting hang
on yeah I don't have anything to drop
let's do them rook right here Bishop
takes pawn I guess oh wow I could do a
rook check it feels like I'm running out
of gas though let's take with the Queen
I don't want a piece arriving here one
day so I want to drop a pawn here and
maybe a rook here I have a bishop to
work with I have some good control I
want to connect I want to get something
here pawn a bishop bishop might be good
maybe throw a rook somewhere here I
don't know
two minutes mm-hmm let's go here nopon
drops with check I could take that one
but if I go here they drop upon enough -
all right hmm
well it's kind of open near my king
let's see how they react to this they're
going to put upon somewhere there huh
let's do that takes takes of threatening
Queen takes f6 right now let us see I'm
really baffled with how many points are
racked up like that already alright get
out of there Bishop yeah you got that
don't you
let's do this okay
take what the knight take here now hmm
top man it's tough look they're not
quite sure what this is even doing okay
it's threatening this but suppose they
just take hmm even on time I wonder if a
strategy oh okay yikes
man they have their position covered
really well
well um I don't know I guess here hmm
yeah they have so much so many pieces
around there King tough too tough to get
through
hmm all right let me get another piece
in somehow Bishop there huh
okay seems like they could just hunt
down my night tell the pawns add more
pawns and they started with yeah all
right chop the bishop bishop trap didn't
see that one coming did you
all right let's just put pressure on
them on the clock here we go all right
take something mm-hmm
alright let's take that and put
something there maybe there was better
okay okay there we go now we're cooking
there we go you got some stuff brewing
that's me yes take it
twenty-third I got 12 shooting for the
front page
shooting for the front page well that's
doable
front page fourteen twenty minutes to go
man
okay I learned something from that one
it's on cubed oh boy
okay you go with a quick Bishop c4 let's
do this don't know if it's right
okay let's develop I only have one
bishop
let's go here pin them clean trade in
early Queen trade we both have the same
rack of pieces here could drop a knight
on this square let's just do that
develop defend Wow look at you look at
you okay
pawns are more valuable than a bishop
could be could be two pawns a bishop and
a queen here we go here we go I feel
some pain I feel the pain what are you
talking about me start with that that's
how you bring the pain pawn drop on g4
equals pain there you go
oh you sneaky got you don't worry about
this you continue with your own attack
don't be so distracted Wow Bishop in the
corner you're asking for trouble
like smothered mate stuff Wow are you
asking for trouble I just want a knight
I want to take out a knight and then
drop a knight here how can I make that
happen let's start with Knight here
defends this a bishop drop kill him
chase him away mate it's also linked
with this square which is another thing
trending here I should have a good one
here
I should have something
okay come on now come on now
come on I were taking pieces and we're
continuing to take stuff just continue
to take stuff is the plan there you go
keep taking stuff
pac-man mode you have to watch out for
the pac-man tactic you know tough - okay
night I just want a night man
give me a night land a fork some how can
I put you somewhere where I could get a
night all right tell you what Queen here
you can't go too far away kill the night
night drop on e - GG see how simple all
right let's see you see the threat your
king is in a dangerous spot you have a
nice Fork though you have a nice fork
maybe they're setting up something with
a pond check anyway I should consider
that they have a queen also I'm putting
my queen out there maybe too early
mm-hmm what's this about
just take that night
I'm not afraid of a pun I'm just I'm
just going to take that pawn if you drop
it oh no no no I've been lining that up
for a while
there it is ninety-two mate 16 14
minutes to go front page is where it's
at
go for the front page strike it F to
scholars mate maybe just maybe you could
just win by regular means huh just by
regular means boom boom alright let's
see if they're going to go pawn hunting
you going to do that alright let's try
this no idea if this is a good strategy
but give it a go
might be too early they're considering
not taking I love that alright let's
preserve him I got what I wanted some
weakened squares here here drop
something they're not I mean alrighty
hmmm
we'll take that night if he goes here I
have a fork get the queen drop a queen
on f2 mate crazy house scholars mate
Queen drop on f2 okay now let's take
that guy out
Knights are dangerous scare him away
you're going to grab my Knight pawn drop
here let's go here
Knight drop or a pawn drop with tempo
hmm do I want to drop the knight right
now now let's liven it up see if they
give me some more material to work with
if they take here I also get some file
where they're trying to cover some
squares around their King let's let's go
to these squares Knight into here they
could have a night whenever they want
sideboard 102 that huh all right let's
do this oh yeah
okay the Queen
that's matin one and then two got it
back to tournament whole front page I'm
a twenty thirty seven thirty six thirty
twenty six twenty six twenty four twenty
s okay maybe just three games left
maybe that's already mistake okay here
we go
bishop in let's pin that night okay
hmm okay let's start immediately with
this hitting it c2 too early to drop
maybe wow I'm going to take that yep
trying to make something happen now
around there King hmm can you tax
can move it away and think about
dropping upon in a bishop next Queen
here I could meet with this okay you
take the rook mmm bishop here and then
dropping a knight here would be nice hmm
I could take the rook in the corner
let's do this first
hit it f2 oh man they have a bishop move
here check okay that's one less piece I
have to worry about them dropping though
I have a check here this is a move as
well develop a piece attack the Queen
grab that rook Wow this can't work I got
a lot of fuel Knight here with check
this is indirectly defended why I should
have
from how good sideboard
their King is more accessible some gaps
here okay take the rook let's drop this
in here first yeah this is right okay
let's do this also defending this square
no piece drop here Queen here I could
drop a pawn or a bishop they resigned
I'll take it back to term and I have 24
37 36 35 31 hmm okay two games in maybe
three let's see go right after f7 really
alright let's do this
can you take and then take two pawns
really let's open it up get rid of their
furthest advanced pawns that way they
have a different more difficult time
connecting pieces on the support point
on these support points okay things are
opening up their Kings should be the
more exposed now no we're not even doing
that huh
well let's take that guy to ponds I have
a plan hmm take here and then take here
let's give that a shot so there's
another pond I'm going to have a lot of
ponds take there it's check I'm going to
do a block oh really I don't believe
that no way no way that could work
there's got to be something good here
let's start with that seems dangerous
okay now we're going to take the Queen
if they take with the night I have Queen
here and that's me that's me back to
tournament WWOOF 28 37 36 35 31 hmm I
could get two more games in I can maybe
sneak into the podium maybe already less
than six might get paired up with the
fast and furious one huh
Oh see they have speed bumps as well
honey like that okay oh is this the top
guy he is let's see how he is beating up
everybody how is he doing it all right
alright ready then Bishop in hmm alright
let's do this let's throw the knight in
there take with the bishop or pawn I'm
not sure let's go with this hmm alrighty
just kind of observing these squares
here maybe a bishop on this square huh I
can make that pawn flinch
good things happen take the knight and
drop him here actually or even here they
have a knight drop as well maybe they're
considering a sack and then a night jump
let's see you know this may be the last
game actually am I talking about two
games this might be the last one
mm-hmm they're a-ok I think he needs to
go hang on let's take him with check
first I got two knights and let's get
back to pinning him where do I drop a
knight right away he's tricky drop that
night right away strike at this square
just like they were doing on the f4
square
oh really that's how it's being defended
let's bring the heat the pin maybe grab
a pond drop a night here do they have
any good Bishop drops Bishop's aren't
that good of a piece okay bit of a
painful move if I move him
Bishop checks here are going to hurt me
let's try that well they could still
take it no things are going to get wild
rook takes pawn rook takes Bishop drop
with the fork my king I feel like my
king would be safe to her safer over
here take him out I think I'd like to
play just a longer game of crazy house
it's really so much to consider very
interesting push
grab some material yeah let's give it a
shot here there mm okay
it's getting it's going to get crazy
okay they have a lot that they could
work with so do i okay what do they have
lined up here huh
how about
hmm let's do something direct take this
pawn with check ouch didn't see that one
coming I should have though I should
have looked directly at the squares
offend my king here pawn drop King takes
rook let's start with that pawn drop if
King here okay they're having none of it
alright we got it we have to take up and
get some initiative here I could drop my
rook in I could take their queen this
has to be good unless I could run away
right they're not going to hurt me too
bad threatening me Queen to e7 I
overlooking a mate I should be able to
run Bishop check
you
hmm
am i falling for a mate no one police
say no discovered double check they have
okay so King here rook check I just take
it they don't have anything in the
reserve tournaments over by the way
threatening mate and I made it oh my
goodness
that's me I have to take oh that Bishop
was there Gigi mmm I would have liked to
have gotten that last one but it wasn't
meant to be
I was so close that wasn't that was
enough to do it though I guess I had to
go in this direction huh but mmm see my
concern with this was a let me tell you
what I was thinking here my concern was
on King here that they could do a bishop
drop but I could block I was thinking I
had to do this and then I get my Queen
and lots to learn okay back to
tournament and the winner is Ferrari
with a beefy 41 all right 4139 38:35 33
32 28 is where i finished seventh 136 in
this one very nice all right to the 136
of you who took part in the crazy house
tournament games all alright that is a
nutty variant
you